oh how about this one aryun kalyan
from india with a profile picture of me
love it if you don't like it
there are plenty of less narcissistic
streams around there
okay let's go for something standard
the rue lopez d3 spanish
one of my old favorites
a4 the old-school
way of playing h3
let's see what he's got
h6
[Music]
where are you supposed to put the
on d2 or c3 the knight
thingy
oh well i'll put it on c3
like that's uh now we'll go to d5 i
guess
i think knight h5 is coming bishop a2
take on d5 take on d5 drop the bishop
back
oh c5 i was going to say i'm aiming to
to play d4 but he prevents it
immediately
so that means i gotta i gotta aim for f4
instead
but i think i'm getting some some some
small trick very small trick for you
f4 the point is
if ef4 rook f4
um then take with the bishop i'm i'm
still threatening both e6 and h6
and with knight c6 obviously i wouldn't
take an e5 because
1095 attacks my queen but here
i'm sort of keeping all the threats i
think
and unless i am completely mistaken
which i am frequently
then i got a great position here not
just good
great position
and he really needs
needs to find a way to make his position
great again here
otherwise it's going to be a lot of
trouble
i don't see it one interesting try would
be knight to d4
but apart from maybe i can go c3
um i think i could just go
bishop d4 and he could not take on f4
because queen g7 would have been mates
and here i just take this one
just run away and i don't think he can
ever really create any serious threats
against my king here
grabbing the open file while i can and
my knight is just too strong
queen d6 now he does get an ending with
a pawn down but
it is it is not going to be enough for
him i think
i can think i can even just run
just run
and take this one
a little trick at the end
now make sure at the end actually there
is absolutely no
hurry to go get a queen with the eights
i can
bring the king king around first to make
sure his king doesn't run to the
queen side with any kind of because he's
boxed in and yeah it can happen
whenever whenever i want